hey what's up you guys happy Friday this
is the daily Deni and once again I'm
throwing the rule book out the window
and I'm dedicating this episode to
another awesome influencer and comedian
please welcome to the daily Denny Jenn
McAlister oh my god jennxpenn in the
house you guys what's up thanks for
coming hang out with us
we have lots to talk about but first I
want to play a little game where do we
do this with our guests two truths and a
lie
tell me to to to the lie about yourself
but but but we'll reveal it at the end
of this episode okay yeah okay
my family owns an anteater at a zoo my
birthday is wrong on my birth
certificate the first time I had peanut
butter and jelly sandwich I was 18 years
old 18 years old in year two first PB&J
all right you guys have any guesses
leaving in the comments section right
now we will get to at the end but you
got my wheels turning I'm thinking all
right all right we got to talk about
four seven we do he's in three yes I
mean you're so stoned I can't I'm so
excited
well this time you guys are on the
island you guys are at the beach I'm
sure in Sandy's gonna ensue yeah what
can you tease about this season so yeah
this season you know it's the same group
that we love but we're in a new location
the gang like scores a trip to a place
called Beach Island and so it's a winter
break trip that we're all going on and
there's a lot of drama there's a lot of
new characters the foursome kind of has
like some new rivals which is
interesting another squad yeah
unexpected friendships and you know Andy
got a boyfriend season two but as you
can tell from the trailer if you've seen
it there's kind of a love triangle like
going on there between her and the two
guys not a bad gig for you not about you
at all you know Andy has some decisions
to make this season that's so fun what I
what a journey though right right what
an army she's like was struggling to
find a man and now she's got to compete
for so how old it all play out what can
you tease how will that play out for her
um I mean things work out for her and I
think it's it's crazy there is so much
that goes on this season I feel like
seasons 1 and 2 have just like built up
like the perfect storyline for this
season I really think it's like the best
season what is a bigger challenge for
you is its script
did or is it you know doing your thing
on your channel and like opening up to
your fans
that's a great question did get drunk in
front of your very vulnerable yeah you
know they're challenging for different
reasons you know cuz acting is
definitely a challenge but I like doing
acting that's my only job there
you know there's everyone else does
everything else so I don't have to worry
about battery whereas like YouTube
I still do everything so you know it's
challenging to come up with like a new
idea every single week for sure
we actually pulled the community ask to
submit some fan questions for you so I
think you're a couple now um let's see
this person whose name is Niall Horan on
YouTube wants to know who are three
people you most admire and why three
people I'm most admire okay off the top
of my head immediately I have to say my
mom I think my mom is like she's made me
the person that I am today for sure she
is so inspirational to me a great sense
of style she does she did a great job
you did a great job picking out your
clothes yes you kept some of those
dresses you told me I did I love my
father thanks mom my best friend Jordan
from back home definitely definitely
just a great person and he's just like
so authentically himself it's very
inspiring to watch and then also let's
do a celebrity right right yeah yeah I
like brie Larson she's my favorite actor
so very inspirational oh I love
everything she does yes she's great oh
let's see
Leslie Lopez wants to know what inspired
you to be what you are today Wow
Oprah's Next Chapter eight I know you
know I draw like lots of my inspiration
just from my life you know so I that
sounds so no but I don't have to be
especially a youtuber you know you have
to be your authentic self
exactly so yeah probably just my life I
mean I've been making video since I was
eight so it's kind of pulling from
everything around me absolutely well
that leads us to our next question from
Sierra she wants to know what was it
like growing up on YouTube as a teenager
oh yeah you know very interesting right
those phases are
online forever they're talking I'm 21 I
started when I was 13 so it's weird it's
like a time capsule but like a time
capsule about every single person can
see if they wanted to all right it's
time to do the review for the two cheats
that a lot okay so let's recap okay
your family owns an ant eater your birth
date is wrong on your birth certificate
and the first time you had a PB&J was 18
I'm gonna say the lie is the birth
certificate oh no no it's wrong on your
yeah it's wrong it's wrong I didn't
think that was allowed like I figured
that would you get me I know I was born
on seven nine and I weighed 7 pounds 11
ounces I switched to 9 and 11
that's so funny okay so wait which one
is it okay I guess I guess I guess I get
one more your family does not own it I
love them I thought that was true though
my best friend's family owns an anteater
okay I took that from cuz I was like I
need to get some like a unique life okay
good and I asked her before we start
this interview were you from originally
I think Pennsylvania totally right
killed a few zero you had a PB&J when
you're only 18 yes what was that
experience like for you you know I
didn't like you don't like it of course
not I know okay I think I was too old
right missed the boat I didn't describe
I love this are you like a ham sandwich
girl yeah well thank you so much for
coming to hang out with us today you
guys season three of four some hits
YouTube read on November 1st so please
go check it out go check out jennxpenn
of course on YouTube and like and share
this video all right I love you guys
we'll see you on Monday have a good
weekend